hey guys
how's it going
my name is pete i work at
facebook on the instagram team and i
work on a javascript library called
react
and before we begin
i'm not here to pitch you to use react
or teach you how to use react because
those don't really make for particularly
interesting talks
instead i'm going to focus on the ideas
behind react there's a couple of things
that we do a little bit differently than
alternatives and implementations change
all the time
but the fundamental ideas between the or
underlying the way that you architect
your system and build applications
tend to be universal and applicable to
anything
so i hope that what you get out of this
talk is kind of oh they came up with
this idea that works for this use case
maybe i can apply it to whatever i'm use
i'm doing
so let's talk about building user
interfaces and what makes user
interfaces a difficult project
um the thing that differentiates user
interfaces from other types of software
development is is this statement
you know it just doesn't feel right and
it's it
the fact that user interfaces are human
verified systems makes them pretty
difficult to build
a lot of the existing techniques and
tools that we have for developing
systems don't work as well so for
example testing is a lot harder it's
very hard to test whether something
looks correct and we approximate it with
things like selenium and screenshot
testing and stuff like that but it's
just hard
additionally we have designers that work
to make really simple user interfaces
that appear really simple on the surface
but a lot of times underlying that that
apparent simplicity is a lot of complex
state under underneath it
and finally the tools that we have
available today um
don't really fit uis a lot of the time
so um i think that we're still in the
early days of good layout systems
static analysis is helpful but doesn't
really get us all the way there
at the end of the day building uis is
just a fundamentally complex thing to do
the good news is we're javascript
programmers and this is our job our job
is to manage the the art of programming
and the art of programming is the art of
organizing complexity of mastering
multitude and avoiding its bastard chaos
as effectively as possible
really famous computer scientists said
that way back in the day
so how do we avoid this bastard chaos
what i try to do is i try to be
predictable and another word for for
predictable is reliable
so
i want to build a user interface that
behaves exactly the same in my
workstation in development as it does in
production and it as it does in some
foreign environment that i'm i'm not
using so
how would we make user interfaces more
reliable
if anybody here has built a user
interface before they've probably heard
on the web they've probably heard of
data binding
and microsoft started using this
on the desktop in the 90s and it's kind
of in the past couple of years gotten
popular on the web in javascript
and
i think dijkstra must have come up with
this as well because he talks about it
in the 60s and says we should do our
utmost to shorten the conceptual gap
between the static program and the
dynamic process to make the
correspondence between the program and
the process as trivial as possible
it's a pretty wordy quote but basically
what he's talking about is when applied
to data binding
we're taking two dynamic processes we've
got the user interface render to the dom
and we've got your business logic
somewhere in the javascript and we're
making the user interface look a lot
more like a static program relative to
this changing program over here that's
running your business logic
the tldrs we sync some data over here
with some data over here and the system
manages that for you rather than you
doing it yourself
so
in computer science we have another way
of doing that and it's called reactive
programming
so you can think of data binding as
almost a polyfill for reactive
javascript and a reactive dom
now
all polyfills are abstractions on top of
some other thing and unfortunately data
binding is a very non-trivial
abstraction
and that means that it's going to be
leaky and leaky abstractions don't
necessarily lead to simple systems
so we had a traditional data binding
system at facebook a couple years ago
and we found that it led to very complex
hard to maintain systems so we decided
to explore other alternatives for
structuring our applications
and i'll go into the our solution in a
second
but
dijkstra also says that simplicity is
prerequisite for reliability and
simplicity is a word that people throw
around all the time
what's simple for you might not be
simple for me
so it's very hard for us to decide what
is simple and what isn't simple but
there's actually an objective way to
look at simplicity
that rich hickey came up with who
invented the closure programming
language
and he says that simplicity is all about
interleaving or the lack of interleaving
so
if you think about solving a problem in
your kind of day job you look at a piece
of code
how many different concerns are
interleaved in that piece of code and
the more concerns that are interleaving
that piece of code the more stuff you
have to fit in your head in order to
understand a problem and solve it and
predict what's going to happen
now this has nothing to do with
familiarity
so i ask you know as we kind of progress
through these different ideas
some ideas might not be familiar but
that doesn't mean that they're not
simple
look for the lack of interleaving
all right so the traditional way that we
implement data binding on the web and on
other platforms is something called key
value observation um this is what ember
knockout backbone meteor they all do
that apple also does it on ios with core
data and it's built around the idea of
observables and computed properties and
an observable is basically a value
sitting in memory somewhere and whatever
it changes it triggers it sends out a
signal saying that it changed and in
javascript that tends to be a callback
then you've got these other observables
that we call computed properties that
recompute their values whenever their
dependencies change and then you create
this kind of
graph of these computed properties that
represent your application so some data
that changes over here in your business
logic through computed properties
eventually ends up in the dom
so let's walk through an example and see
how this works
in an application
so let's say that we're building some
sort of rotten tomatoes for businesses
so we've got the name of the businesses
or we've got the
json response from the server and it has
the name of the business and um a number
of upvotes and down votes
and we might have a large number of
these
and we want to render a really beautiful
ui that looks like this
where we basically take
we want to sort them by the number total
number of votes so we want the most
popular businesses we want to show the
percentage of votes that were up votes
we want to only show the top three
this is actually something that's pretty
realistic at facebook where we have you
know giant list of friends we only want
to show the top friends for some sort of
query
so
um to demonstrate kvo i need some sort
of real world implementation and i
picked ember mainly because the team is
really high quality and if i want to
demonstrate that there are problems with
the underlying ideas i better pick the
best implementation of those ideas
so this is um the first step with
building this in ember
where you basically build a template
that renders this this unordered list
element into the dom
now already we see the um the
abstraction of data binding leaking into
your program
these aren't programming constructs
these are constructs invented for domain
specific language for expressing data
binding into the dom
so you can't create functions here you
can't use your regular javascript
toolbox it's a leaky abstraction that
you're you're forced to do this
but it's driven by javascript and
there's more code to this project so
let's dive into the javascript side
we'll make a function that computes the
total number of votes just a helper
function because we're going to do it in
a couple places
we model the company
and we provide this computed property of
the score and the score is that
percentage that i showed you and we take
the the total number of up votes divided
by the total number of votes and we
massage it until it looks like a
percentage
and this is an example of a computed
property and you can see the dot
property syntax there that says hey
whenever the upvotes or the down votes
of this company change make sure that
the score is updated as well
then we we model the rest of our
application in something i'm calling app
model and um this is where we do the
ordering and the sorting and the slicing
we take the companies and we sort them
by the total number of votes descending
and then we slice off the top three and
whenever the companies change um we make
sure that we update this this top
companies list by that dot property
syntax
and finally um this is just some
boilerplate to glue it together and this
gets you know the 100 companies from the
api and puts it into the system
so
i wrote a little test case that adds a
random number of upvotes and down votes
to all of 100 companies in our
application
every half a second
and i took a little screen recording of
it and it looks like this
so you can see that the the scores are
updating but do you see the bug
if i'm adding a random number of upvotes
and down votes to 100 companies you
would think that the top three by total
number of votes would change all the
time
so um i really appreciate the code
review you guys just did for me but we
just pushed this to production and it
was a bug
so where's the bug
the bug's right here
um
yes whenever the company's array changes
we update the top companies but we
actually need to also
remember to look at the upvotes and the
down votes so we're introducing yet
another domain specific language to
support data binding
and not only that we have to think about
data binding in our core domain logic we
can't only think about the javascript we
have to think about
the entire data binding abstraction
additionally looking at this computed
property how do i know that i have to
look at the upvotes and downloads
i have to look at the the way that total
votes is implemented and hold that piece
of the program in my head while i'm
holding the computed property in my head
as well
um so when i apply that fix it works as
you would expect and and the percentages
update and it
now if anybody here uses ember or is a
has used a data binding system like this
before
you probably think that i don't know
what i'm doing and i should have made
total votes of computed property
that brings this great quote to mind
which is intellectual solve problems and
geniuses prevent them
by taking functions out of my toolbox
you're saying i can't use functions
anymore with data binding i can't use my
traditional javascript tools that have
been developed with 50 years of computer
science research behind them for
something that was invented a couple
years ago
so
that kind of stinks
there's another way that's a little less
leaky i think called dirty checking
which is the approach that angular takes
and if we wanted to build a widget like
this which is a profile picture with a
user's name next to it a very common
widget you'll see on on facebook or any
social site
um
you'd make some markup like this in in
angular which which looks great right
like we have this reusable widget and we
say what the what the data binding is
and that it's getting the user from the
the controller's user
and the javascript that drives it
um is passing data through this thing
called scope now if you don't know
angular um i'm gonna it's the the
details of this aren't particularly
important
um but you have you see that we're
passing the data into scope
and
our method of composition in in
angular's data binding system um
requires you to pass everything through
this scope and you must consume it with
directives
so if i want to build this avatar
i need to and i want to put a reusable
profile picture component inside the
avatar i have to create an actual dom
node by putting it into a string and
specifying these arbitrary kind of
scope parameters in these in these
directives so the way that data flows
between directives and angular is not
the way that data flows in any other von
neumann programming language something
they invented a couple of years ago and
it's to support this data binding case
the point is not that we can't build
applications this way or we can't build
performant applications this way the
point is that we can do it in a simpler
way
and the great teams behind angular and
ember have spent a long time trying to
get these simple and i don't think that
they're simple so if they can't do it
i think there's a problem with the
underlying ideas
what if we got underlying language
support for this what if we had a truly
reactive javascript in the dom
if we were building this simple
application that i showed earlier
we would write something like this we
would say okay i want to call a function
that renders my data based on my json
that i got back from the server and i
want to put it into the document body
i'll create a helper function just like
i would create a regular helper function
in javascript
and i'd start creating dom nodes now for
the purposes of this i didn't include
the whole
document.createelementdance and i just
provided a helper function
but we create an unordered list element
and we we pass it some some companies
sorted by the total number of votes
we slice off the top three
and then for each company in that array
we render a list item
with the title and an expression that
represents that percentage
now
i think that this looks pretty good but
some people think that this is is too
concise or spaghetti code the good news
is this is a programming language and we
have methods for solving that
abstraction so we can pull out some of
this code into a separate function and
kind of reduce the level of nesting if
we want
and additionally
we can unit test the row separately from
the rest of the application
why can't we build applications like
this that's just javascript we didn't
have we didn't change anything about the
semantics of the language
the problem is that js is not magically
reactive
and more importantly the dom is stateful
we can't just blow away the dom whenever
we want to change something we need to
to maintain scroll position in the state
of form fields and all that stuff we
can't see that white flash
so uh we really wanted to build
applications in this style at facebook
so we built our our own abstraction on
top of the dom that we call a virtual
dom
and it's a less leaky polyfill for
reactive javascript than the dom
and the reference implementation of it
is called react and it's on github and
it's been out for about a year
so
this mythical reactive javascript
actually is valid react code
and it's important to keep in mind that
there's no data binding artifacts and
you have really no idea that there's any
sort of magical data binding going on at
all because you've written code just
like you normally would with your
regular javascript toolbox
so
i don't have time to dive into the the
deep implementation details but i'll
give you a quick overview
so whenever any piece of data may have
changed in the system
we re-render everything we run all of
your rendering code
to a virtual dom representation
that return value of the uls and the lis
then we diff that previous
representation with the next
representation by walking them
and when we see a difference we only
update the dom with what actually
changed
and this leads to very expressive code
so in computer science the expressive
power of a system is basically the
breadth of ideas you can express in it
but i think a more actionable definition
is practical expressivity which is a
measure of ideas
expressible concisely and readily in a
system
so
with the virtual dom approach
there was no sort of of observable or
data binding abstraction inside of your
code
we only look at the the return value of
your functions so your code is a black
box and you can do whatever you want in
it and you can can call out to
third-party libraries if you want
and this leads to just really concise
and expressive way to build applications
so i've talked to a lot of
a lot of
teams working on competing ideas and
they don't buy it and the reason they
don't buy it is because they think that
this re-rendering and diffing step is
really expensive and it's going to lead
to poor performance
and intuitively it kind of feels like
that right like why would i rerun my all
of my rendering code for any tiny change
right
again we're programmers and we know the
value of everything in the cost of
nothing
this was actually about lisp programmers
but i think it applies to us as well
so let's look at the costs for using
these various techniques and there are
costs to using kvo dirty checking and a
virtual dom approach
um with kvo i've talked about it a lot
entangling your app code with
observables leads to hard to understand
performance characteristics and bugs
angular style dirty checking is kind of
similar in that you have to use
something that manages your scope as
your unit of composition and that limits
the expressivity of what you can do
virtual dom's
constraint is that we need a signal that
says something somewhere has changed
and now the key difference between the
virtual dom constraint and the
constraints of other systems is that
that's pushed to the edge it doesn't
permeate within the black box of your
user code somewhere outside of your
system whether it's object.observe
in a browser event an ajax response
request animation frame
that signals to the system hey something
has changed rerun the render code and do
the diff
there's another problem which is when
you start introducing domain-specific
languages to support data binding it
reduces the ability to statically
analyze them
so
if you've used angular before there are
some problems with minification there
because of the way that they use the
language and express domains
concepts
in kind of a
a weird way
um and in in you know ember where you
have getters and these and these key
value um dsls you can't run like
typescript to check the values of these
things
so the further you step out of
regular javascript and into this
domain-specific language the less tools
you have in your toolbox to to build
applications
so let's talk about performance
so we build a lot of consumer
applications at facebook and mobile is
pretty important
um i'd actually argue that memory is
almost more important on mobile than cpu
because if you blow a lot of cpu on a
mobile web experience it's going to suck
you're like the user is going to
complain if you blow a lot of memory on
a mobile web experience
ios is going to kill the browser and
you're not going to have any user
experience so i'd rather have a crappy
user experience than no user experience
but it's important to look at not only
cpu but also memory
so if you think about key value
observation i'm going to focus mostly on
key value observation because it's the
furthest from our approach
the bookkeeping required to maintain
that graph of observables and computed
properties is definitely not free
so you trade off maintaining that
representation for re-rendering
re-running your render code all the time
in a virtual dom system
fortunately your render code is usually
very cheap
the number of times that you create
really tight loops in your render code
is very few because you're not really
rendering that much to the dom when you
think about it
because your view is usually smaller
than your model
and in cases where your view isn't
smaller than your model your model is
usually pretty tiny and your app is
usually already performant
uh mark twain had a really great quote
about javascript performance um
i'm gonna dive into some hard numbers
and benchmarks that i did um it's
important that like benchmarking is
really hard and i can't claim to have
comprehensively benchmarked every case
but um i wanted to use it as evidence of
fundamental properties of the ideas
rather than the implementation so
looking a little less at the number of
milliseconds things took in the number
of megabytes of memory used and a little
more at the orders of growth
and the comparison of the different
performance characteristics um over
these problems
um is kind of more what i'm going for
so let's um let's take a look at this
application that we're all familiar with
now um
i implemented it in ember as a as the
reference implementation for kvo and i
implemented it in react as the reference
implementation for virtual dom
i made sure i used the minified versions
and and everything
and if we if we have 25 items like
companies underlying that list and
remember we're only rendering the top
three
uh performance doesn't matter like it's
it's it's a wash with 25 items
when we bump it up to 10 000 items you
start to see a pretty significant
difference in performance
i mean we're talking like orders of
magnitude here
and
what why is that the
case well it's all about orders of
growth is everybody ready for some big o
notation excited okay
um so if you're familiar with bigo
notation it basically describes you know
how your your app how long your
application is gonna or how your
application's gonna perform based on the
size of the input
and o event is linear which means you
know as we add more stuff it gets you
know slower at the same rate
but it's important to actually think
about what n is
so a lot of the performance
characteristics are going to depend on
the size of your underlying data model
and the size of what you actually render
into the dom
so i'm going to use o v to say hey this
is the number of like dom nodes that i
render in and of m to say hey this is
the size of the underlying data of my
application
so we found for real applications that
actually have performance problems um
the size of the the data you're
rendering is much smaller than than the
size of your data model so um the two
most recent performance things i worked
on were a giant infinite scroll sortable
data table which could only show 10 rows
but may have had millions behind it
um and a search type ahead on a mobile
device where you know you might have
100 or 200 cached results but you're
only showing five in the viewport
so if we go back to that little chart
showing off um performance
characteristics you'll see that a kvo
system is roughly constant time when you
update it and if you think about how it
works we have an observable it triggers
a signal and then it might call a couple
other computed properties but it's
effectively constant time based on the
size of the input if you think about
virtual dom where we diff all of your
output
it's going to be linear in the in the
size of what your output actually is
because we have to walk everything and
compare it
if you look at memory though this is
where we we see a lot of wins with the
virtual dom approach because kvo needs
to maintain a
representation of all the data in your
application um and and their
relationships between computer
properties which grows based on the size
of your model as opposed to virtual dom
which only cares about what's actually
rendered because that's the only thing
it needs to keep track of
so
obviously i really like react and my
first example is going to be really
really positive and pro react but i
actually think it is a pretty realistic
representation
but let's look at a worst case scenario
so let's flip that assumption upside
down and say that our view is going to
be a lot bigger than our model
and we're going to update a single
needle in this giant haystack so we do a
lot of diffing
and a lot of that diffing is is
basically completely unnecessary right
so we're gonna render a thousand items
and ten thousand dominoes
and if you look at the performance
characteristics here
um focus on the warm updates
and your intuition about how the the
performance would compare it seems to be
right here right like the
um the o of one is is going to be much
faster than the o of v because the v is
so big um and it's about
um
it's definitely noticeable it's 40
milliseconds and users can notice
anything over 16.
um so if this were a traditional data
binding approach we disable data binding
at this point and do it manually
with a virtual dom approach you would
optimize this just like you would
optimize any other piece of javascript
because again it's a black box and we do
it with memoization
and in our reference implementation of
virtual dom called react uh we provide a
hook to let the system memoize that for
you
and we can basically say hey for our
example
only diff rows that have different
upvotes or down votes that have changed
in this tick
and we have profiling tools that will
help you
tell you where to put that
so if we add this
six line hook to our code
we can bring down that 39 milliseconds
to 7 milliseconds in our worst case
scenario
now that's still 10 times slower
than a kvo system and i don't think that
we can get much better than this
however it's still within a single
request animation frame the user can't
perceive this in the worst case scenario
so the question is is it worth the cost
of losing that expressivity
and performance problems when your model
gets really big and you're rendering a
subset of it
to gain
less than a frame in the worst case
so my friend who works on ember told me
this
so i should probably stop
um but but when we came out with react
and we talked about this virtual dom
there was a lot of misunderstanding
people think that we
wrapped the dom um
to
get performance gains and eventually
it'll end up in the browser or something
like that
it's not true it's all about the
fundamental way that you express uui
so the secret of the virtual dom
is to keep things simple because we want
to build sophisticated applications we
need to have simple underlying
abstractions to build them on top of and
virtual dom is a way of expressing your
ui in a more simple way and having the
system manage updating the dom for you
and because of this and because
virtual dom lets you express your ui
logic the way you want to in a black box
this is the most expressive way to build
user interfaces on the web today
and lines of code are not a great metric
but it is a little more concise and
there's a lot less ideas you have to
think about because you already know
javascript and using the same
abstractions that you always use no
observables domain specific languages
for binding to dom nodes data
conversions from a third-party library
into your observable system and back
again that kind of thing
your unit of composition doesn't look
like this
looks like this
and we've actually seen um kind of real
world um
uh data that indicates that this this
applies to kind of projects that aren't
just at facebook if you look at the the
bindings for firebase on angular for
example they're like 300 lines of code
and there are no bindings for react
because they're five lines of code
because it's just passing javascript
data structures from one system to
another you don't have to translate it
into the data binding system
so lines of code aren't a great metric
but orders of magnitude i think do
indicate something
so again performance is not the main
goal but if you're thinking about
performance most workloads are fast out
of the box and in the worst case it's
very easy to optimize at the end of your
project
without breaking out of the virtual dom
abstraction
so i hope i've convinced you not to
trade simplicity for familiarity
thanks guys
you